well come in to this video wargasm yeah
I got this guy quite often there and it
seemed okay it's playing a good setup d
5 g 6 is quite good against the
fianchetto get into a pancetta greenford
and he's playing this more interesting
line c6 is also good this is a little
bit more enterprising and the best thing
for him as I have absolutely no clue
what's going on here hmm night c4 I
really have no idea 92 maybe 493 4449 v3
I have no idea about the line just
stumbled into it and term I don't know
it what about this well mmm move like f3
looks very loose Knight b6 see also as
Queen B 6 yeah maybe more the Queen
it looks kind of weird yeah because 9
p-3 was an idea but still if it takes on
d4 I can flick at night see form and b7
as a checked yeah I really hope that
this is quite quite okay this look look
very stable somehow but I can always
rely on this good bishop on be too
that's a very good piece to have okay
let's activate this piece if he goes to
c7 I will probably just play a form
keeping my night save on c4d 5 is also
an interesting way to play yeah maybe I
should start with that actually if he
goes to c7 thats I should start with d5
and then play a form yeah that makes
sense yeah this is something that I do
like I like to trade this ahead ahead 1
1 night too many that same here this is
something that I think helps me just a
moment
yeah it's okay i want to make sure that
be five is not coming quickly I'm not
sure office if I want to play night to
see form it looks very normal yeah but
this is also quite quite nice young to
get this in this big Center maybe I can
play even if or F for this kind of thing
that would be nice okay he's trying to
earn trade of this bishop I'm just
playing Bishop here so that he cannot
trade off this so easily helix space so
trades will help him yeah cannot avoid
that trade relief all right that's it so
that's a really good position for wide
let's see 23 and f4 or the captcha mom
if I take it he will keep my night so
not good but this is a good move
yeah so f form or is this premature
don't think so I have to be quick errand
oh wow if I just take it clean Knight f3
how does he defend the pawn klk Queen
Queen takes Queen takes Knight f3 king
of six as possible but this this is
something that I can play and if he
takes now on air for I'm ready for he
fire them even immediately this is an
idea takes f takes a 485 but probably
just G takes a strong he just lacks one
or two moves to coordinate but he does
not have the coordination at the moment
and it looks very critical I don't know
how he defends this yeah I will just
recapture and it's the the easy easy
solution yeah yes this check
gr it would be nice to have more time in
this position then I'm pretty confident
that i can even allow the screen reform
but i'm not i'm not totally convinced
especially like when the Queen comes to
deform and possibly the night but this
is this this is probably really good
right come let's do that I really
haven't calculated that much but it
should be good really and with the pawn
here so let's check I can take f64
rookie seven I can play e6 I was
thinking about e6 mostly but then he's
got 96 mmm i probably shouldn't have
done that night coming to you six sd-6
is a problem because of 94 and ce4
hanging I'm stupid right I'm a stupid
person why didn't allow that ma'am very
bad play he was completely busted him I
just have to avoid that okay that's
really bad now i was thinkin ye six but
96 is just so strong time morning yeah
the shame the shame from this great
position
yeah I want a quick rookie 70 I'm not
carrying much about the c-4 pond check
my d4 check very uncomfortable from this
position what is shame to always that's
what's trading a check you will see was
really completely lost check
black resins and what I don't understand
did I miss a maid or something and why
did he resign this I mean thank you very
much but I don't know why
I'm kind of stunt I really don't know
what happened here okay yeah I what I
really like to know is I'm kind of
claiming all the time that I was winning
but i want to check if this is actually
true okay the compass stock razon 1.1 so
it's not totally off and how am i
winning now f5 know that that move was
not on my agenda and okay it is very
good like 1.2 1.3 it yeah it's an
interesting idea of course I'm this is
this is really nice am I'm sorry going
for 96 and detecting the bishop so f5
was a move yeah I kind of had this hunch
that there should be something here
something good 'if I've was nonsense
maybe I can start with this Queen here
yeah but he always has 96 this is very
time sensitive I cannot play any other
move its really f5 and f5 and a problem
yeah the same i really i didn't see that
after this this is so fatal just a very
bad way to play very bad yeah I lingered
for almost 1 minute year and this is
this is totally stupid I probably also
have some some some more simple ways to
to go about it but fi was really strong
I didn't consider the move at all I was
completely completely concentrating on
e5 ideas and I did not consider this at
all yeah it it uses this Bishop that is
out of the game and he cannot play any
other move yeah this is Jack this is
killing him really quickly and we had
game and he just resigned for for no
reason I don't know what it was okay
well i hope you liked it thanks for
watching